Jujutsu kaisen is absolutely insane
right now but there's even more going on
than meets the eye Yuji itadori has
finally returned to center stage in the
story and his new power is the only
thing that can stop sukuna and I am not
exaggerating Yuji is the key to
everything he is Humanity's Only Hope
Yuji was created as a result of kaku's
human experiment he has the power to
learn sukuna innate technique he has the
power to manipulate souls and you have
no idea what this man is actually
capable of if you've been
underestimating Yuji up to this point
because you've been more focused on Gojo
and sukuna you got to watch this video
until the very end you will not be
disappointed you guys know the drill if
you enjoy my jjk content and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain special grade status by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now
finally this video will of course
contain Jutsu kaisen manga spoilers so
please proceeded with caution you have
been warned back in chapter 238 we saw a
demonic looking Yuji attack sukuna right
after sua's fight against kosimo and
then the focus shifted to Kaku and his
meme battle against the failing comedian
takaba but while the meme fight has
definitely been one of the fights of all
time to me the more interesting thing
about the focus shifting to Kaku has
been the information we are getting
about kaku's secret master plan that has
been over one ,000 years in the making a
critical component of that plan is Yuji
and yuji's very birth was orchestrated
by kenju for the specific purpose of
creating an artificial sorcerer who
could one day surpass even sukuna
himself remember all the way back to the
first chapter of Jutsu Kaizen when
yuji's dying Grandpa tried to tell him
about his parents but Yuji just cut him
off and said to stop trying to act cool
before he dies I really wish Yugi didn't
stop his grandpa from talking about his
parents because as the story continu
Contin to unfold the dark truth about
yuji's parents has been revealed bit by
bit and the more we learn the more
messed up it gets as soon as we meet
Yuji we realize that he is superhumanly
strong although no reason is provided
for this at first even back then the
story was hinting that something was off
with Yuji and that there was more to him
than meets the eye soon after we saw him
eat one of sukuna fingers megumi was
sure that this would kill him but
instead of dying Yuji became a vessel
for sukuna and to make things even
crazier once sukuna enters his body
through the cursed finger Yuji is still
able to prevent sukuna from taking
control which is simply unheard of
sukuna is literally the king of curses
History's Strongest Sorcerer And Yuji is
supposed to be just some regular high
school kid who loves Jennifer Lawrence
but as we know now Yuji is not just a
regular person early on in the story
Gojo reveals that yuji's ability to
suppress sukuna within his body even
after consuming multiple fingers is an
incredibly rare ability that only
appears once in every thousand years so
what makes Yuji so special why does he
have superhuman strength and speed and
why does he have the power to suppress
and control the king of curses inside
his body the answer to this question
goes all the way back to the very thing
that yuji's Grandpa wanted to tell him
in the first chapter of the story it
goes back to yuji's parents Jinn and Ki
itadori in chapter 143 we saw a
flashback that Finally Revealed yuji's
mom and dad for the first time and this
brief two-page backstory reveals the
dark true Yuji tadori is not a normal
human he is a human experiment and he
was deliberately created by the evil
sorcerer Kaku the flashback shows yuji's
dad holding a baby Yuji and talking to
yuji's Grandpa the Grandpa is trying to
talk to his son about that woman but
Yugi's dad says that if the conversation
is about her he's just going to leave
the grand grandpa says JY you can live
your life however you like but give up
on that woman you'll die JY replies by
saying don't talk about such things in
front of Yugi they say babies remember
more than we think the grandpa keeps
going he says I know you wanted a child
and that didn't happen with Cy but her
death was and then he is interrupted by
a woman saying father-in-law what are
you talking about the woman is of course
yuji's mother Cy and this woman has a
large scar on her forehead the same type
of Scar that ghetto develops after his
body is hijacked by Kaku so now we know
what happened yuji's father jyn was in
love with a woman named Ki and at some
point she died but jyn couldn't give up
on Ki and on the idea of having her
family with her because of this he
accepted a dark deal with Kaku kenju
used his innate technique to bring Ki
itadori back to life but he did so by
simply hijacking her body and then Jinn
and kenja inside K's body produced a
child Yuji Yuji is biologically the son
of jyn and Ki but the one who gave birth
to him was not Ki herself but kenju
inside of K's body yeah like how
freaking messed up is that this
immediately makes me question what
yuji's father was thinking did Kaku
trick him into thinking that he could
bring the real Ki back we do know that
kenju can access the memories of someone
whose body he hijacks so maybe he used
K's memories to copy her personality and
make jyn think that it was really her
when in reality it was just gjaku
pulling the strengths or maybe jyn knew
the truth but he wanted a biological
child with Ki so badly that he simply
didn't care although I find that kind of
hard to believe because yuji's Dad would
have to be insane to be okay with
something like that the truth is that
we've never actually seen yuji's Mom
before she was hijacked by Kaku so we
don't know what she was really like we
only know what her curse technique was
because it was revealed in chapter 208
when kenju left K's body he still
maintained the ability to use her
technique this technique allows the user
to negate gravity and the curse
technique reversal of this power allows
the user to amplify the gravitational
pull around them so okay now for the
million dooll question why in the world
would Kaku go through the trouble of
becoming yuji's mother Kaku is a
1,000-year-old sorcerer who is planning
to use cursed energy to force everyone
in Japan to evolve Beyond Humanity so
where the does Yuji fit into all of this
The Tragic Truth is actually quite
simple when you think about it
throughout his thousand years of life
Kaku has conducted countless human
experiments including of course the
creation of the cursed womb death
paintings during the Magi era these
experiments created cursed objects that
possess mixed blood of both a cursed
spirit and a human and eventually three
of these cursed objects were incarnated
into human flesh in the form of choso
eso and kisu the disturbing truth is
that these three human experiments have
a younger brother and his name is Yuji
itadori even though we still don't know
everything about yuji's true Origins we
know that he was deliberately created by
Kaku as part of his human
experimentation and since Yuji was
created some 150 years after choso and
the others we could assume that Kaku
made a lot of advancements in his
experimentation techniques by the time
he got around to creating Yuji Kaku is
the reason why Yuji has such a special
super for human body and even now nearly
250 chapters into the story we still
don't understand the full power and
hidden potential of yuji's body but now
that the story has truly kicked into
high gear we are finally about to find
out as I mentioned earlier in chapter
238 higuma and Yuji attacked sukuna
following sukuna successful victories
over both Gojo and Kashima in the final
panel we see that yuji's arm has pointy
demonic looking nails and fingers just
like sukuna did back when he was
possessing yuji's body this has led to
speculation that Gojo's prediction from
way back in chapter 12 is finally coming
true if you'll recall in chapter 12 Gojo
said that in due time yuji's body would
actually learn to use sukuna cursed
technique meaning that even after sukuna
leaves his body as he did when he
decided to possess megumi Yuji will be
able to essentially copy Suk kuna's
curse technique and Yugi may be about to
use that very technique against sukuna
himself meaning that we're going to see
something like sukuna fighting sukuna
now obviously as the strongest sorcerer
in history sukuna has some amazing curse
techniques that would be an incredible
asset for Yuji if he really gains the
ability to use them we are not 100%
certain what sua's original inate
technique is because he demonstrates the
ability to use at least two distinct
types of attacks the first is the
ability to launch invisible cuts and
slashes at his opponent and the second
is the ability to launch fire-based
attacks at his opponents including fire
arrows so suuna is also able to use
reverse curse technique which allows him
to heal his injuries extremely quickly
including very serious injuries like
lost limbs sukuna possesses the
extremely rare ability to heal the
bodies of other people using the reverse
curse technique and he can even use this
to heal his own burnt out curse
technique as we saw during his fight
against Gojo sukuna is capable of using
domain amplification which is an anti-d
domain technique that allows sukuna to
envelop himself in his own domain in
order to resist the curs techniques and
domain expansions of his opponents these
are all techniques that Yuji could also
potentially learn to use now and then
there's the question of sukuna
incredibly overpowered domain expansion
sua's domain is called malevolent Shrine
and it is one of the absolutely
strongest domains in the history of
Jujutsu kaisen when sukuna expands his
domain a dark and creepy Buddhist Shrine
appears behind him the domain's
guaranteed hit attack is a ruthless and
continuous slashing attack that will
tear apart everything inside the domain
except for sukuna himself there are two
types of slashing attacks cleave and
dismantle and the attacks will continue
until sukuna is weakened to the point
that he can no longer maintain his own
domain cleave is suk's Attack of choice
for enemies who possess cursed energy
while dismantle is used to destroy
inanimate objects due to its ability to
unleash a barrage of endless slashing
attacks malevolent Shrine is essentially
a weapon of mass destruction that can
kill hundreds of civilians and destroy
an endless number of objects within a
200 meter radius on top of that sukunai
is able to control the range of his
domain within certain parameters and he
is capable of expanding his domain
without actually closing the barrier he
used a binding vow to create an escape
route from his domain in exchange for
the ability to expand the effective
range of his guaranteed hits since
malevolent Shrine doesn't have an outer
barrier you cannot destroy the domain
just by destroying the barrier the only
way to destroy the domain is to injure
sukuna so severely that he can no longer
maintain his own domain in addition
sukunai is able to change the conditions
of his domain using a binding vow and
this allows him to do things like like
remove the domain's guaranteed hit
effect in exchange for increasing the
domain's overall power last but not
least sukuna has the ability to
transform his flesh we first see this
ability manifesting once Yuji consumes
sukuna fingers and becomes his vessel
even though Yuji is able to maintain
control of his body for the most part
and he successfully prevents sukuna from
taking over sukuna is still able to
manifest a mouth and eyes on yuji's body
through which he can see and speak he is
also able to do this against the host's
will without having to actually take
control over the host's body and this
ability to transform his flesh also
allows him to attain his final form
presumably sua started out as a normal
human sorcerer but he eventually
developed the ability to grow two extra
arms two extra eyes and an extra mouth
on his stomach this final form is the
optimal form for a jutu sorcerer in
battle and sukuna managed to attain it
by transforming his flesh in chapter 238
Yuji seems to be exhibiting the early
stages of this flesh transformation as
his arms begin to turn demonic with
strange looking flesh and long pointy
nails but I know what you're thinking
okay sure Yuji is a superpowered human
experiment who is clearly far stronger
than the average human and sure his body
may be learning to use sukuna cursed
technique that's great and all but that
doesn't guarantee that Yuji will be able
to actually defeat sukuna even if he
learns to use sukuna curse technique
after his battle with Gojo we know for
certain that sukuna is the strongest
sorcerer in history and he had literal
centuries to master and perfect his own
curse techniques even if Yuji unlocks
the ability to use that same power there
is no way that he will instantly become
as strong as sukuna even though he is a
quick learner Yuji would need years of
training to get anywhere close to sukuna
level but there is one thing that could
set Yuji apart from sukuna and that
could actually give him an advantage
over the king of curses in fact
this is the very reason why Kaku created
Yuji in the first place he designed Yuji
to become the king of souls when kenju
created the death paintings about 150
years ago you will notice that their
powers were related to the body like
blood manipulation and Decay as in decay
of the flesh but I believe that 150
years later Kaku perfected his method of
human experimentation and he realized
that in in order to create the perfect
artificial Jutsu sorcerer one who could
rival even sukuna himself Kaku would
have to create someone who can
manipulate more than just blood and
flesh he will have to create someone who
can manipulate the soul itself we all
know by now that Yuji has the unique
ability to hurt not only the body but
also the soul which he proved in his
battle against mahito mahito confirms
that Yuji possesses a unique
understanding of the human soul and that
he is a aware of the Contours of the
soul but makito just assumes that this
is because he has sukuna Soul inside his
body at that time and yet even after
sukuna leaves yuji's body yuji's special
connection with soul related Powers
continues in chapter 222 we also saw
Yuji apparently switching his soul with
kusakabe so that he can train martial
arts inside of kusak Cab's body while
kusakabe takes possession of yuji's Body
yuji's Soul also managed to survive the
death of his body for an extended period
of time before being revived by sukuna
most people assume that this was all
sukuna is doing but I don't think that
just anyone could have survived this
situation even if sukuna wanted to bring
them back to life I believe that yuji's
soul is unique and that is part of the
reason why he survived we have to
remember that in the world of Jutsu
Kaizen a soul is an actual entity that
exists and that Souls do survive the
death of the body Yuji Soul survived the
death of his body and when when Gojo
seemingly dies his soul is transported
to an airport where he meets with the
souls of his long dead comrades and he
learns information from them that Gojo
himself had no way of knowing this
proves that Gojo isn't just imagining
his friends at the airport he is
actually communicating with their souls
and these Souls continue to exist even
long after their bodies died so not the
soul in Jutsu kaisen is not just a
symbolic religious concept it is a real
substance that can be manipulated in
battle just like makito was able to do I
think that Kaku created Yuji as a human
experiment not just because he wanted
him to become suk's vessel but also
because he wanted him to become the
ultimate jiujitsu sorcerer the one who
could one day learn to use sua's own
curse technique and then surpass even
sukuna himself with his own innate
ability to manipulate Souls sukuna is
the king of curses but Yuji just might
be the king of souls the soul King if
you will and Yuji might be the only
sorcerer in history who has a real
chance to surpass sukuna just as his
third parent Kaku had always intended
what do you guys think is yuji's secret
inate technique the ability to
manipulate souls and will this be the
power that allows him to make the
difference in a battle against sukuna
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you're looking
for more epic jjk content to watch right
now check out our full Jutsu Kaizen
playlist link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
for that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help this channel attain special
grade status by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are so close and
every single subscription counts